désormais nous déprogrammant aussi en
pédiatrie ont des programmes les enfants
monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui ont des programmes à tour de
bras avec je cite les professionnels
concernés des effets collatéraux
préjudiciable irrattrapable pour ne pas
dire mortel sur nos patients
[Musique]
face à cette situation au début de la
semaine
le système de santé francilien s'est
engagée vers ce qu'on appelle le pilier
le palier 4 de la montée en puissance de
la capacité hospitalière
il faut en effet que les hôpitaux
publics et privés franciliens armes 2250
lits de réanimation
juste pour les malades qu vide
[Musique]